we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here's something interesting
that came in yesterday on the voicemail
line your deepak let me ask you a
question who is going to play steven
miller this weekend on Saturday night
when I yeah
which cast me is gonna get it or will it
be somebody outside of the cache discuss
this is great yeah I have a sense of who
would be really good to play Steven
Miller on Saturday Night Live the guy
that plays Sheldon Cooper on Big Bang
Theory Jim Parsons I think could do an
awesome awesome Stephen Miller that
would be my pick that would be a great
guest appearance I mean it's funny how
even this happened on Sunday that
Stephen Miller went around on all the
talk shows and made a fool of himself
the show for Saturday Night Live the
next week was already written
yeah these saturday night live shows are
writing themselves and in fact they're
not even that different from reality
Saturday Night Live has to get crazier
and crazier to make it clear that it's a
parody because we're in a situation
where the Trump administration is
effectively a parody of itself
tough job it's an a it's an abundance of
riches and also a difficult situation
for Saturday Night Live Live writers at
this point what if SNL goes with another
woman to play Stephen Miller as they did
with Sean Spicer that's another good
idea I don't know who it would be but
that's that's an interesting idea we've
got a great bonus show for you today I
will tell you about a lot of the things
going on behind the scenes that the
David Pakman show early survey results
etc etc please sign up david pakman.com
slash membership coupon code if you want
it I voted 17